In the Marvel Universe, the Eternal known
as Ikaris has been around for a very long
time — hundreds of thousands of years, in
fact. But to many comic fans, he's still
something of a mystery. This is everything
you need to know about Ikaris from Eternals.
Perhaps the most important thing about Ikaris
is that he isn't just any other Eternal. He's
the so-called Prime Eternal. But
that hasn't always been the case.
After the god-like Kronos' fateful experiments
with cosmic energy leaves his mind separated
from his body, his two sons, Zuras and A'lars,
fight a conflict over the future of the Eternals.
When Zuras wins, A'lars leaves
for Jupiter's moon Titan,
where he will later become father to Thanos. Then,
after the remaining Eternals form the collective
Eternal consciousness known as the Uni-Mind,
it chooses Zuras to be the Prime Eternal.
Zuras is later killed in battle with the
Celestials and Thena is selected as the
new Prime Eternal. In 1986's Eternals #9,
after Ikaris accuses Thena of treason over
her loyalty to her Deviant lover, Kro, Thena
passes on the role of Prime Eternal to Ikaris.
Being the Prime Eternal means more than getting
a fancy title, though. Among other things,
whoever is named Prime Eternal is given the
privilege of initiating the formation of
the Uni-Mind — an act that has saved both the
Eternals and Earth on more than one occasion.
Ikaris boasts a wide array of abilities,
including impressive super strength and
durability. He expertly wields cosmic energy
that's often seen blasting from his eyes,
and he can manipulate this
ability in various ways.
Unsurprisingly, these powers serve him
well in battle. In 1977's Eternals #14-#15,
Ikaris goes toe-to-toe with a cosmic-powered robot
designed to look, act, and display powers similar
to the Incredible Hulk. While not the real deal,
the cosmic-powered Hulk robot is no pushover.
And on top of that, Ikaris has faced all kinds
of similarly powerful challengers over the years.
Similar to the other Eternals, Ikaris can fly.
And while they aren't his most used abilities,
he's also been shown to have both the capacity to
teleport and use some low-level psychic powers.
If you're familiar with the world of ancient
myth, then you've probably already guessed that
the name Ikaris is inspired by Icarus, the boy
who flew too close to the sun. And in a mid-'80s
Marvel miniseries, the connection between
Ikaris and Icarus became much more literal.
In Greco-Roman myth, Icarus is the son of
Daedalus, a genius forced by King Minos to
design a labyrinth to contain the terrifying
Minotaur. When King Minos imprisons Daedalus
and his family so that the secret of
the labyrinth can never be revealed,
Daedalus constructs his own flying
machines out of bird feathers and wax.
Upon their escape, Daedalus warns his son
not to fly too close to the sun, but Icarus
ignores him, and when the wax of Icarus' flying
contraption melts, he plummets to his death.
In 1986's Eternals #5, it's revealed that, in the
Marvel Universe, the Eternal Ikaris was actually
the inspiration for this story. Centuries ago,
Ikaris had a son named Icarus. One day, believing
his father to be imprisoned by Deviants, Icarus
attempted to use a mechanical flying device to
find his father. Like the Icarus of myth, the boy
flew too high and eventually fell to his death.
After learning of his son's fate, the Eternal
named himself Ikaris to honor his fallen child.
One of the X-Men's most infamous villains is
Apocalypse, who first shows up using that name
in 1986's X-Factor #5. It's since been revealed
that Apocalypse had faced a number of heroes
before he met any of the X-Men, however.
For example, he fought a younger Thor in
2013's Uncanny Avengers #6, and at one point he
even faced off against Ikaris and the Eternals.
In the 2000 one-shot New Eternals: Apocalypse
Now, the evil mutant unleashes his latest
sordid scheme. Ikaris and Apocalypse don't meet
face-to-face until toward the end of the story,
but when they do, it's suggested that they're
actually old enemies. The details are left a
little murky, but Ikaris refers to the
villain as "En Sabah Nur," suggesting
their last encounter was centuries ago, when
Apocalypse was better known by that name.
Ikaris also claims that he'd believed Apocalypse
had died in their last meeting. At first,
that might not seem like much of a reveal —
after all, as a popular Marvel Comics villain,
Apocalypse is legally required to die
and be resurrected every few years.
But the fact that Ikaris and his
brethren so thoroughly defeated
Apocalypse as to believe him dead proves
just how formidable these heroes can be.
"Who do you think's gonna lead the Avengers?"
"I could lead them."
Since the Eternals tend to live separate from
humanity, it's perhaps understandable that
some of them aren't exactly thrilled
to be sharing the Earth with humans.
Consequently, some Eternals aren't quite
as dedicated to their safekeeping as
they should be. Ikaris, however, has always
done everything he can to defend humankind.
Ever since ancient times, Ikaris has gone above
and beyond to protect the people of Earth.
From his guidance of Noah's Ark to safety all
the way up to his allegiance with the Avengers,
Ikaris has always advocated for the humans,
despite having advanced beyond them in many ways.
This is why, when most of the Eternals
leave Earth after their battle with the
Inhuman villain Maelstrom, Ikaris is one
of the few selected by the Uni-Mind to stay
behind — and continue to use his powers to
protect those who can't protect themselves.
The idea of a superhero taking on a relatively
mundane job is nothing new. Spider-Man has been
a photographer, Daredevil has been a lawyer, and
the godlike Superman has enjoyed a thriving career
as a reporter for the Daily Planet. Regardless,
it still feels like kind of a shock that the 1985
Eternals miniseries finds the noble and powerful
Ikaris working as a professional wrestler.
In 1985's Eternals #1, it becomes apparent
that Ikaris has joined the ranks of Marvel's
Unlimited Class Wrestling Federation as
Ike "The Iceberg" Harris. The issue even
shows him in action in his wrestling digs,
and judging by the applause and cheers,
this is hardly Iceberg's first time in the
ring. Of course, it's eventually revealed
Ikaris didn't join the UCWF because he enjoys
hitting people with folding chairs. In fact,
Ikaris has been climbing the UCWF's ranks for
the chance to take on the wrestler Enigmo,
who's actually Cataphrax the Mighty,
a Deviant villain in disguise.
The UCWF was one of the more prominent
Marvel fictional organizations in the 1980s.
Along with Ikaris, a number of other
heroes have joined and wrestled in the
UCWF — though the most prominent
was none other than Ben Grimm.
Ikaris and the other Eternals claim the
distinction of starring in one of the few
comic books that Neil Gaiman has written for
Marvel Comics. Comic book-wise, Gaiman is best
known for his groundbreaking DC/Vertigo Sandman
series, though he's written a few projects
for Marvel, too. In 2003, he wrote 1602, which
introduced early 17th-century European versions
of most of Marvel's most popular heroes. Then,
after Marvel acquired the rights to Miracleman,
Gaiman wrote subsequent issues for that long-lost
character. And in 2006, he teamed up with the
legendary artist John Romita Jr. to bring to
life another dormant property: the Eternals.
The mid-aughts Eternals miniseries
begins with each of the godlike beings
stripped of their memories and living as
ordinary humans. The speedster Makkari,
for example, is living as Mark Curry, a
med student. Sersi is a party organizer,
Thena is a scientist working for Stark Industries,
and Zuras is an alcoholic homeless man. It's
eventually revealed that their memories have been
stripped by the mischievous Sprite, but before
that becomes clear, it's Ikaris who sets out to
find the Eternals and reawaken their old memories.
A few years later, the Eternals
fell to a horrible fate,
and Ikaris was the last of them to
survive. When Avengers relaunched in 2018,
it was led by a storyline involving the Dark
Celestials, a group of evil cosmic beings.
After the corpses of the true Celestials fall
to Earth, the Avengers set out on a quest
that ultimately reveals a dark secret about the
Eternals, humanity, and the Celestials themselves.
When Iron Man travels to the Eternals' home of
Olympus, hoping to get some more information about
what has happened, he instead finds a massacre.
The only living Eternal he finds is Ikaris,
and even then the Prime Eternal doesn't
survive for long. Ikaris stays alive just long
enough to reveal that his people erupted into
madness when they learned their true purpose.
Essentially, the Dark Celestials meant for
humanity to act as a virus against an army
of insect-like monsters called the Horde, and
the Eternals were meant to cultivate that virus
and get humanity ready for the harvesting. Before
he succumbs to his wounds, Ikaris gives Iron Man
access to the Uni-Mind, which the Avengers are
later able to use to defeat the Dark Celestials.
In 2021, the Eternals returned for the fifth
volume of their eponymous series. This story
finds Ikaris and his immortal compatriots brought
back from the dead — they are eternal, after all.
Set loose in a battle against Thanos, Ikaris
is killed and rebirthed again, and only then
discovers the horrible truth of the Eternals'
immortality: that they're resurrected at the cost
of human lives. Unable to end this process without
endangering the Earth, the Eternals set out to
solve their problem... leading them into a fragile
alliance with their old enemies, the Deviants.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Marvel Comics
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.